salut les p'tits menthe à l'eau oui je
vous appelle les petits mentale au lieu
de la team mentale aujourd'hui je fais
ce que je veux on est en plein été on
fait ce qu'on veut lui aujourd'hui je
vous donnais 5 astuces pour bien
négocier ça fait quelque temps que dans
les commentaires vous me demandez de
faire une vidéo sur ce sujet là on est
mercredi c'est le jour des astuces ça
tombe bien mais il ya quand même des
nuances entre négocier son salaire
négocié un prix dans un magasin à
négocier avec quelqu'un donc au lieu de
traiter les sujets un par un dans un
master class je me suis dit je veux
faire plus tôt les cinq astuces
fondamental pour une bonne négociation
c'est applicable à toutes les
négociations quelle qu'elle soit de
l'argent de poche jusqu'à se faire
embaucher quelque part ou à renégocier
son salaire par exemple également pour
obtenir un prix dans un magasin ce sera
à vous après d'adapter ses conseils
suivants la situation dans laquelle vous
êtes et je vous le dis une négociation
c'est commence quand la personne vous
dit non
première astuce une négociation ça se
prépare en avance alors très en avance
ou quelques minutes avant peu importe ça
c'est suivant l'ampleur de la
négociation et du projet et du but mais
vous devez vous préparer mentalement
préparer votre argumentaire préparer
anticipé un peu les phrases d'opposition
que vous allez entendre pour cela il
vous suffit de vous mettre à la place de
la personne qui est en face et de
réfléchir à ce que vous diriez à sa
place pour vous contrer comme ça vous
préparer déjà la contre argumentation
deuxième astuces savoir qui est en face
alors si c'est votre patron vous savez
qui est votre patron si c'est pour un
entretien d'embauché fait des petites
recherches avant qu'elle ait sa place
dans l'entreprise depuis combien de
temps il est là est ce qu'il a un
pouvoir de décision fort ou pas est-ce
qu'il va devoir vous revendre lui encore
une fois quelqu'un d'autre si vous êtes
dans un magasin essayer de voir qui est
le vendeur ou la vendeuse de le regarder
de l'observer un petit peu de comprendre
ce rapport avec les autres vendeurs est
ce que c'est une personne qui est un peu
chef est ce que c'est un stagiaire dans
ces cas là le stagiaire pourra pas
négocier avec vous trois préparer des
solutions alternatives existent
potentiellement des solutions
alternatives qui peut vous convenir dans
votre négociation anticiper les à
l'avant ça vous permettra de les sortir
comme des joker au moment où la personne
dirait écouter sur l'été pour autre
chose dit pas là il faut avoir la
réponse donc préparer des solutions
alternatives des choses qui peut vous
convenir et préparer les halles avance
pour être toujours très déterminés dans
votre négociation après quatrième
astuces le marchandage et les
concessions très important les
concessions pourquoi parce qu'une
négociation
contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est
fait pour que les deux parties soient
contents de ce qui vient de se passer il
y en a pas un qui la prend le pouvoir
sur l'autre s'est pas réellement ces
négociations on le pense souvent
dans le sens finale et tous les
négociateurs vous le diront quel qu'il
soit même s'il ya une notion de pouvoir
on veut que les deux parties soient
contente donc tout du long les deux
parties vont faire des concessions pour
un moment donné se trouvait en face à
face régler un petit peu le curseur
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on voit
souvent des négociations où il y en a un
qui parle à l'autre ici et puis la
personne baisse un peu et puis l'autre
un effort et un moment donné il se
retrouve ça c'est l'exemple de base mais
il faut le généraliser et penser que
quoi qu'il arrive il va falloir
marchander et faire des concessions soi
même donc effectivement peut-être mettre
la barre un peu plus haute
au départ pour pouvoir la redescendre
plus facilement je voulais dit au début
de la vidéo une négociation ça commence
quand la personne dit non et bien plus
généralement quand la personne est trop
ferme c'est à dire mais des ultimatums
des choses ne sont plus possibles
ne vous laissez pas intimider par ça
vous n'avez rien entendu ou en tout cas
ne réagissez pas assez bien souvent
d'ailleurs qu'une question d'ego donc
après on a envie derrière de mettre
encore plus d'ego c'est pas comme ça que
la négociation a abouti hier donc ne
fait pas attention aux ultimatums que la
personne vous mais par contre si vous
vous en mettez un même si c'est pas un
gros ça peut être par exemple un moment
donné vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur un
prix avec le vendeur dans un magasin et
vous dites bonbonnes tout et c'est comme
ça c'est pas très grave
tant pis voilà je je je m'en veux agir
en acheter ailleurs partait vraiment
partait jusqu'à temps qu'il vous
rattrape et si vous ratera pas partez
quand même parce que c'est ça le secret
d'une bonne négociation c'est d'être
prêt à renoncer si vous avez un objectif
un but avec un argumentaire vous savez
jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à descendre
puisque vous êtes préparés à l'avancé
c'est pourquoi il ya beaucoup de
négociations qui sont un petit peu
éventée par exemple pour l'achat d'un
objet c'est quelqu'un veut acheter un
objet il essaye de négocier mais de
toute manière quoi qu'il arrive il le
veut et même au prix fort c'est pas très
grave donc qui il joue à essayer de
négocier et ça le rend heureux
en face le sait le perçoit et va faire
aucun effort parce qu'il sait que la
personne n'est pas prête à renoncer si
vous êtes prêts à renoncer
c'est votre négociation n'aboutit pas
alors vous ne serez que plus fort merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous aura plu j'espère
aussi que ça vous servira un petit peu
cet été et puis pendant que vous êtes là
peut-être s'arranger pour pour un petit
pouce en l'air si vous avez d'autres
conseils à donner pour la négociation
n'hésitez pas à nous les mettre dans les
commentaires
l'élite tous avec grand plaisir et ça me
ferait très plaisir de vous voir aussi
échanger vos propres astuces on s'est
regardé la vidéo de demain elle est très
importante n'hésitez pas à faire tourner
cette vidéo est à vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir puisque le mental
blog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
an
depuis le 1er janvier alors rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao